today's guest is a fiery little Sunbeam
she's a political pundit she's a host
from Fox Nation she is she is a
polarizing figure and she is a voice of
conservative politics miss Tommy Lehren
[Music]
you really nice families still there how
many people when you go to the hole when
you say the whole family my whole family
still lives there I only see my mom and
dad I don't see the whole family do you
have siblings no really you're an only
child are we recording ours is off huh
are we just part of it that's fine yeah
okay you're an only child I am no way I
don't think I'd get along with others my
mom always said that I would kill a
child another child if there was another
child I mean if you had a sibling that
was a yes staunch leftist I think you
guys would have a tough time at dinner I
don't think they'd survive oh really oh
you put them down huh yeah early
probably real quick um how hard is it
for you to live in Los Angeles cuz
you're really like you are a voice you
were a right wing voice you know you
were like the you're like the frozen one
of the frozen characters but in like gum
but of like on the on the far right you
know we're not far right but on the
right yeah people say far right though
and then it's like oh it's all right
it's this ya know like I'm a boy I'm
more conservative decide yeah ya know I
don't cross the 405 yeah I stay in the
South Bay it's still not great you know
does it get risky like any people treat
you yeah well I'm pretty identifiable
yeah you and I have that in common with
the hair right so I'm pretty
identifiable but ya know I get pushed I
get tripped I get kicked
I get heckled but only when people are
in big groups so they would never say
something to me what I want
people follow me around grocery stores
sure why like why you following me can I
help you I'm at the grocery store you're
I'm not a you know a rare animal or rare
species I'm a conservative in California
Here I am but they fall like weird men
only follow me around and they think I
can slow the pervert right point-blank
that's right yeah what do you want to do
yeah that's all the time okay yeah yeah
that's me
do you um do you feel like you bring
like you asked for like I feel like you
like the you like the fight yeah people
have to get comfortable being
uncomfortable and conservatives I agree
with that
bothers people and so it's like I'm not
gonna the reason that Donald Trump won
is because he was the first Republican
he's not like Romney or McCain who
apologized for everything he said this
is who I am I love it dude Romney seems
like a guy that sells socks to rich
people well yeah he just like seemed
like a tall guy who has a lot of socks
dude
good-looking probably my first political
crush was Mitt Romney until things took
a turn really yeah also Paul Ryan do you
know who that is
is that the guy from Kentucky no
Wisconsin Senator Paul Ryan can you
bring up a picture and please yeah
Congressman Paul Ryan he was a Speaker
of the House I think - do you have curly
hair khana no let me see if he let me
see if it's a find it I know Paul well
I'm from Wisconsin so you know him well
yeah attractive fellow right mm-hmm oh
that guy yeah Wow you think he's
handsome
well I mean you're not pulling up the
best photos go to the gym photo old
school there we go see other people what
well I mean some of these are fake well
go to the good ones go to the Time
magazine one see and is he the guy with
the really old wife that everybody
always jokes about no who's that
I'm the guy who's married like a like a
woman that's like 20 years older 20
years older oh I don't know who that is
it might be somebody else we'll have to
do a game where we put all the
politicians for you hmm you know
governor Newsome you didn't know who
that was no yeah so we need to just
we'll do a game yeah like a like a
family tree we'll put him together for
you so you know who's running the
country on the top you know big old Don
yeah yeah Oh Don's the easy the redhead
man no um is he naturally red-haired do
you think Donald Trump yeah there's not
red it's got an orange tint
well not red but I say redhead I would
say blonde more I would say he's a
blonde would you say he's a blonde oh
yeah I would say maybe he is a blonde
yeah I think he's a blonde he's got you
know it gets a little orange in there
but it don't think it's a role I've had
a similar cut I've had that couple of
woman that would be a good choice but
some of his cards um have you ever met
Donald Trump yeah
was it pretty cool how do you feel about
it uh he's called me before and those
were good conversations were you nervous
about it no no not really I mean it's
something different about President
Trump being President Trump you don't
feel like you're talking to a politician
here right there and just talk to you
just shoot the [ __ ] pretty much yeah
like I'm in the Oval Office is pretty
cool you know getting a lot of things
done great things for the country
stay tuned a lot of good stuff coming
yes that's just how he is right what you
see is what you get people have to
appreciate that yeah yeah some great
business stuff that he's doing you know
I mean I think is definitely a roll call
just in him that you know America
doesn't need to spend some time taking
care of itself and not trying to take
care of or in be involved in everything
you know cuz I think at a certain point
there's just not enough resources to
take care of the whole world and I could
be wrong but I just don't feel like
there is because it starts to seem like
people are having a tougher time what
was gonna ask you about oh dude so there
was a guy did a couple years ago did
some guy try to set me up with you years
ago do you ever remember this or no no
who would that be some major like in the
DM or something no see this was like
five years ago I was on I used to go on
Opie and Jim Norton they had a show it
was like an older guy he kind of looked
like remember that game um guess who
remember the game yeah yeah well you
guessed the person he looked at up Nick
yeah he looked like an old guy on there
kind of you look up old guy that was on
guess who board game and I and he knows
me yeah he said I know where and I and I
and and I don't know if he said I'm
gonna try to set you guys up or if I
said something but he um yeah click on a
couple people we got a source this
person yeah yeah it's not David it's not
Franz either did he have glasses we're
playing the game it was a mixed kind of
between Tom Tom in the bottom yeah Tom
in the bottom yeah was he in politics or
what was his deal I mean there's a lot
of people that kind of look like that
okay sorry and a mix between Tom and
oh my god Peter looks like a trend a
little bit of a transvestite if you look
at Peter Oh bottom left yeah as a batch
job
you look like Paul from guess ooh okay
well I'm not helpful at all but anyway
like Bernie Sanders next to Peter which
one that one looks like Paul and then
yeah Paul looks like Bernie Sanders and
then Peter looks like Bernie Sanders
after the transition it doesn't look
like look I can make a knot huh after
Bernie Sanders is on the Real Housewives
of Orange County then you get Peter
natural jump um do you think Bernie will
get the nomination no really no no it's
gonna be good old corn pop Joe Biden no
way yeah I think Bernie's gonna get it
and I think solely because of his do
they vote for it is there a vote there's
a vote for it right well we vote in
primaries so in the primaries it'll be
between so Bernie will have a chance
then yes but he doesn't have a chance
it's gonna be Elizabeth Warren better
known as Pocahontas and Joe Biden that's
who it's gonna come down to and then
it'll be Joe Biden no way I think it but
here let me tell you why I think this
because did you see um Bernie Sanders on
Joe Rogan yes it's cool huh yeah no
people like Bernie Sanders but the
Democrats are never gonna let him get in
there not just like they didn't with
Hillary well I mean that was messed up
Halle last year there last time they
[ __ ] just screwed the guy yeah was
Hillary she's got a pattern of that but
how do you just how is there no policing
like listen he got and he got screwed he
didn't win but he got out of that pretty
unscathed he is still alive you don't
cross a Clinton normally and come out of
it without an accidental suicide Wow
so Bernie is still up there shaking his
finger ready to go but he's not gonna
get the nomination it's gonna be sleepy
creepy quid pro Joe Biden Joe give some
good I love it how it's just getting
more and more senior citizen I hope we
end up with like a eighty or ninety or
old in there you know I just want to see
somebody just eating soup basically on a
stream cam 24 hours a day well do you
know who Ruth Bader Ginsburg is they
call it yeah so she's I think we need to
be doing a welfare check
I'm not convinced that she's you know
like kim jeong-hoon yeah or kim jong-il
you know he wasn't around for the last
couple years of that no one saw him fail
Castro same thing oh that's true huh I'm
thinking someone is out there again
somebody took Ginsburg no I just think
that she's doing poorly and they're
making it seem like she's okay
oh they're propping her up cuz listen if
they lose her off the Supreme Court
Trump gets another nominee and then we
go through all that again they need her
to stay alive they need her to be good
oh that's all right there oh she's not
gonna be a lot long well we hope she's a
great you know I'm not a Democrat face
that she's sick like her face is
starting to spoil and I don't mean that
in a bad way
I might have she's a beautiful lady I
know she's I think she was the first
lady on what the quarter well you're
gonna say court we're getting closer a
lot of she is she's done a lot I'm not a
fan but she's done a lot I just don't
think that she is as well as they as
they make her seem like she is because
they need her to stay alive I see they
don't want to get another nominee they
know Trump's gonna win again like
another one maybe three they're all
getting up there in age yeah yeah what
about um did you get a prom in high
school yeah you did yeah was it fun or
not you know where'd y'all go eat before
[ __ ] when you're in Rapid City South
Dakota there's only a couple options
yeah well I didn't go there but it where
I live even now I don't remember but
even now to this day if I go home it's
like if you go to Red Lobster Olive
Garden
that's out there oh yeah that's nice
yeah that's nice what's a pizza growing
up was real nice yeah um but Red Lobster
and all garden still is fine dining and
where I'm from yeah that's that's still
there but you know I in high school I
had a boyfriend boy I was with him for
six seven years almost it was easy with
bad guy horrible really horrible yeah no
it wasn't a good situation did he do
what was what were some of his light
like well like going into college right
so he played baseball
I knew he played yeah I play baseball
and we grew know that she did it again
played baseball easy
checkmate that's a easy one
I could have told you play baseball yeah
well he played baseball and he got we're
in a d1 school went to Las Vegas right
so we both went to Las Vegas together
yes okay were you planning on getting
married do you think oh I dodged a
bullet you did fairly certain he's bald
now I think he's got a couple of kids
wandering around but no it was bad we go
to college he's like listen I we can
stay together but I'm probably gonna
cheat on you because I'm quote King [ __ ]
around here so just so you know yeah
that's not gonna work for me
and then afterwards like crying wow I
can't do this alone I can't
he was really crying oh yeah I know
multiple times I think he called me like
a year ago like boy I really missed out
didn't I yeah you sure did be really
cool it's like yeah you know you could
have been like my sugar mama okay well
he said well you know we didn't know
talk and stuff and see where it goes my
probably not well that was it no no
never look back um six years it's a long
time it's a very long time whenever uh
you said you were an only child whenever
you were when you were growing up you're
an only child
yeah yeah that's crazy do you ever do
you ever did you try to get your parents
have another can absolutely not
who would want that who I guess I've
been home for Christmas last weeks like
who would want somebody else to have to
deal with yeah and someone else have to
I want this for dinner I want that for
dinner I want to use the bathroom at
this No get out of here yeah it's just
just me the one only do you think that's
affected like the way that you see
things like a growing up like the even
like your like political views or just
like the way that you see the world yeah
you like to be independent if you're an
only child you don't depend on anyone
else for entertainment for for anything
really it's just you you got to make it
happen or you don't
yeah so that's that's what I've always
done yeah have to worry about anybody
else
just do your thing just do your job do
your job
hey we could use some more that in
California here people yeah oh this is
definitely a few few look anybody who's
listening out there if you do not have a
job not interested in having one come
here you know what I'm saying you'll you
be okay I mean it's crazy I used to tell
like I used to say if you were an
attractive girl and you didn't
want to get married and you just wanted
to have like a sugar daddy or something
come here
like there's definitely mmm there's a
lot of easy ways out you know there's a
lot of easy ways out or but it's warm
here so it's easy to be homeless here
yeah oh dude I remember when I was in
one time we picked up how to do like a
Loyola Idol they have a school year
Loyola Marymount yeah so we had to do
Loyola Idol and it was just me and a
friend we're judging or we were M seeing
it they're like hey can you bring some
judges so we stopped at a park and
picked up a couple guys a couple
freelance guys you know yeah you did not
100% dude this guy named rich and this
other guy named I want to say Tony Tony
died not on our watch
okay but anyway so we drive over to UM
we drive over to the school and we tell
the kids were like hey we just want to
let you guys know we got two judges we
just picked him up in the park the
curtains open it's to just completely
homeless guys these are original
homeless not more like freeloaders like
now it's got a little more free Lodi out
here yeah this used to be like old
school homeless Bunsen burner cooking up
something you know you know one of the
other homeless people's doing dessert
you know what I'm saying a little bit
more streamline you know this game
playing homeless you know and they judge
the whole thing and at one point we had
to count the votes and one of them
borrowed a guitar from another student
and played a song pretty beautiful did
he get a start
was he you that guy that got the radio
gig you know yeah I don't think so you
didn't help might you just dump them
back off at the park ya know afterwards
yeah we gave him each I think maybe $40
or $50 I'll say 50 to make us sound
better I think we have a meet $40 here
he dropped him off back at the park Tony
him rich and I still see rich every now
and then I'll see him driving by or
getting a blood transfusion he had
something I think one of his kidneys
went out but anyway yeah can you
remember where you went for prom was it
fun
no it was a guy it's horrible
oh yeah no what did you go to prom yeah
I went they had a girl
oh I remember after prom I was hoping to
maybe you know touch a little bit you
know what I'm saying that's nature bra
and I didn't choose that that since
out of me you know and so God just let
that touch and torch sits deep inside of
me and that's how I've always been so
and I got stuck some kid bug the girl I
was seeing went to this party afterwards
and I got stuck riding over there with
somebody else this guy right this dude
who speaking of going bald this guy kind
of went bald in high school right which
is brave as [ __ ] I think today because
people are really gonna rip you you know
like totally bald in high school my
choice my teacher just by Nature
I mean just like keeping [ __ ] eating
lightening his whole life you know what
I'm saying like this dude had no hair
left on his head and he was crying out
her if he was on drugs or what was
happening but we drove over to this
party he's just like hey man we give me
a ride over there I was like yeah sure
man jump in you know we're leaving he
had worn a coat a dress coat that had
shoulder pads in it you know and he
started crying because we're graduating
and he talked about that
oh people thought he said people always
think I look like Damon Wayans we bring
up picture Damon Wayans is he black no
this guy's white okay
so right in soon is yeah I think cuz
he's old he goes and people always
saying hey man you look like Damon
Wayans and you know and I just I think I
might have a career in Hollywood but I'm
afraid to go out there and he started
crying right so I'm in the car I'm like
dude it's prom night right like just you
two in the car yeah just to meet you so
anyway I had to sit there for like 40
minutes and listen to him and he went on
and on him and he looked nothing like
dennah Wayans yeah anyway so that was my
kind of ruined the vibe for ya after
that yeah when I got there the girl I
was seeing was really an Alcoholics when
I got there she was wasted and
fist-fighting somebody she thought was
me how crazy is that sounds like you got
out of that one yeah I would take Damon
Wayans in the car over that one yeah I
would take Dave away go to your school
it sounds like a bunch of real
degenerate oh the first white kid that
wanted to be black ever they used to
call him Wiggles back in the day went to
our school right and nobody had ever
seen it before people are like what's
going on you know you were like a
starter jacket and stuff and they put
him in learning-disabled class
Oh crazy this is a Louisiana yeah
because he wanted to cuz he why he just
you know he was like such a bull you
know he just acted so black you know
didn't everyone go through that phase
though oh definitely know how old you
are
I'm 39 I'm an oh damn you're ten years
old over ten years older than I am I
really
yeah when I was in high school though we
all went through that phase oh really
even in South Dakota right I went
through a phase for a time oh I went
you're like a fitty cent phase yeah
every song but what did you do oh see
you just love the song yeah I mean
there's nothing like rolling down the
Main Street in Rapid City South Dakota
in your life like oh one Malibu
listening to fitty cent listening to I
mean pop lock and drop it that was a
heyday of pop lock and drop it
way that my cousin's funeral yeah oh but
he loved rap music yes do you want a map
of the city or there's a picture of
Rapid City I want to see what we're
looking at so not a man you know like
Mount Rushmore you know that right the
faces that's where I'm yeah yeah I've
been there do you have so see I live
pretty close to there what's the other
city that's near there Grand Rapids no
no that's a whole different state Sioux
Falls is years old yeah I did a comedy
show at a play in Sioux Falls one time
she falls is pretty flat not a lot going
on it wasn't a lot going on it was about
1 hour for about 45 minutes from the
statues from the Mount Rushmore is that
right like four hours oh then it's not
it yeah maybe I want to refuse maybe you
would just well he has about 45 minutes
if you were downtown Rapid City then you
were about 45 minutes from the heads was
there a bar there that you have a bird
in it uh a toucan or something a parrot
that was in the corner
ah he's not Rena Belle bar with parrot
in it can you google nits mm-hmm in
Rapid City South Dakota and Rapid City
South Dakota twelve years older than me
so it could have been in PI air right
there Joe Cory remember that I remember
see it's actually cold Pierre but we're
south ago do we just Pierre Pierre let's
get to the point here yeah just cut out
we also have a city called del foosh OH
sounds like a toilet being flush like
Bell foosh yeah yeah I think it's French
as well well food Pierre both of those
things are there were a lot of French
people
trappers or something oh yeah I could
see the different kind of
and we have now not like trapper
wrappers but just try it for the first
you know do you uh do you listen to any
rap music now or no course I do
oh I've had boy let me tell you I've had
feuds with about every let me tell you
who who hates me
cardi B Nicki Minaj jay-z I'm gonna
jay-z song if you can pull that you
might not be able to play that he might
you might have to get some yeah well
here collision you might have to pay him
pay the man
drug dealers anonymous my voice is in
that song Wow take a listen I said for I
think it's 14 years now it's slipping my
mind for 14 years your husband was a
drug dealer
he sold crack cocaine yes it's in that
song oh wow yeah take a listen
when you do you so it seems like these
kind of feels like you like like you
kinda it's it like you get into like
it's because they're they act like
they're so tough but they're so fragile
21 savages another one I had a feud with
actually really like 21 salaries no sad
but you know I skate away no no ice came
a knock in his door cuz he was in the
country illegally oh yeah they moved him
to Sweden right yeah they well I don't
know where they moved him but you know I
just tweeted about I'm a big proponent
of ice and whenever ice does its thing
so yeah just you know the law came
a-callin yeah but ya know the rapper's
they don't mmm they don't like me that I
wouldn't say that
oh I'll is oh just last week we scrapped
a little bit I saw it I don't know why
it's you a winner if you're gonna write
something back to you to ask you I asked
a friend like hey I need some help me
like I asked a black person give me a
white friend to or somebody that's mixed
or just a white guy from Flint Michigan
but did you ask somebody for help like
ease is good like hey is this good yeah
okay's comedians do that sometimes
you're like if you're gonna do a tweet
sometimes there's something set up
sometimes you'll ask you'll send it to
your buddy first and with he doesn't
answer back and you want to put it out
so you're like what the [ __ ] man check
it out and see if it's funny I need to
post a [ __ ] no I just go ahead and post
it but no matter what no matter what I
say even if what I say is better than
what they said like last week the lizzo
thing like she'll it was impeachment so
she tweeted out like an impeachment with
like a peach in it and then I responded
to and then all the all the Google
Earth's afterwards and all the
wrinkles from like hip-hop unlock and
you know all those yeah was Oh Liz Oh
dregs Tommy like you respond with a
peach right you don't drag me you could
do a lot to me but you didn't in that
instance rights like everyone is ever
it's a concern is like they got dragged
by oh yeah already be dragged she was
gonna dog-walk me and that was her thing
with me yeah it's a lot of I mean yeah
definitely there's only really one well
up that picture there's a lot of memes
that cardi be dog walk you'll you'll see
it everyone they made a convenient well
yeah let's see get some some images see
yeah that was going around for a little
bit oh who's that oh that's pretty big
that's her what kind of dog are you on
looks like I don't know like a pitbull
because if I had to guess well it's
really tough I mean it's just because
there's so much power there's so many
cameras and so many networks that the
people that own them are the people that
that are liberal you know and there's so
few feel like that are just avenues to
be outspoken and be conservative you
know right a lot more conservatives or
people that vote conservative they just
vote right but we're out there right and
it's a smart they would cater to like we
watch reality TV right we watch football
we watch all the things that they think
that they're liberal audience its
conservatives that are watching your
stuff its conservatives in places like
where I'm from where it's cold in the
winter and we watch your sitcoms and all
your crap right we are your viewers like
you think it's these people that are
running around here in LA no these
people are homeless here it's a Midwest
people they can't be outside homeless
they freeze to death those people
watching your stuff yeah but is they a
lien it's like we're not you know we're
not their audience do you feel like
Hollywood alienates a hundred percent
there are so many conservatives in
Hollywood but here's it here's the thing
though but they would it's bad business
to do that but that's what I don't
understand that that that and I'm not
saying that I disagree with you but I'm
saying that
it people a lot of people that work in
the industry are so smart that it would
seem like why wouldn't you see that this
is bad business you know why wouldn't
you see that this is that this just
doesn't help it doesn't help by
alienating you're you're talking about
not alienating people and then you
alienate people you know what they do
though is they look at well like we
never do and Trump supporters they look
at us we're less than morally so it's
easy to alienate us because they've come
up with in their mind that were horrible
evil people and we're racists and we're
bigots and we're all this so they they
can alienate us because that's just how
they see us they don't want to see
anything different they don't want to
talk to people that are not like them
because I'd rather just put them in that
box
yeah and cast them aside so yeah it's
the same thing that they say don't do
you know they say don't behave this way
don't what I don't like is or one thing
it gets me in that space is that that
all people that are basically like if
you're from a rural place and you're
white that you are racist that you are
homophobic and that stuff really it's
almost the most ignorant thing you could
think it's like you think like I had a
guy say oh you're from Louisiana oh yeah
and so obviously you know you know you
probably grew up racist you know and
it's like man just it's just like if you
want to be diverse and you want to be
welcome at least know who is in your own
country first know like it's just such a
narrow-minded thing from people in a
place where people is there's so much
education here in Los Angeles there's so
much you know people that have traveled
and people that have you know had
experiences as a lot of diversity here
you would think that people here would
be able to would at least know who is
also in their country but they don't
like and not everybody I don't like to
put everybody in one category there's a
lot of people here they don't like
people from where I'm from or they don't
want to like them they don't want to get
to know them like we're the flyover
States they look at people from South
Dakota from Louisiana from Mississippi
from other places this country yeah not
really like our kind of people
yeah they're just in the middle there's
just the little people yeah and that's
why Trump won yes he said you matter and
not forgotten anymore and that's what
he's going to win again they're gonna do
the same thing they're so stupid they
did it in 2016 they're doing it even
worse now and they think it's what is it
gonna get him I don't know I think
they're just trying to get ready for
2024 hmm I don't know yeah I mean I I I
do think that Trump is gonna win in 2020
I don't see I just don't
there's too much beef now even it seems
like on the Democratic side I don't know
that much about you know I don't follow
a lot of politics you know I know I was
I know the easy ones Abraham Lincoln
Ronald Reagan one time I was in my
school when I was growing up where I was
walking down the hall behind two
janitors and one of them said to the
other one he goes hey man did you get
the chairs ready in the gym mr. Ford is
gonna be speaking in there later today
and the guy goes president forward and
the guy goes no mr. Ford the [ __ ]
science teacher President Ford you idiot
so but uh anyway so yeah I mean I know a
lot of the presidents and I know like
the lady that bought the bus and then it
went out of business cuz I got into a
bus company for a while back and we went
out of business
kind of like the zoo you almost bought
in Mexico lesson 11 zoo man 1,400 almost
almost
yeah I'm glad I didn't do it because it
was a fight there was a fire down there
imagine that imagine that today's
episode is brought to you by better help
better help will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional therapist sometimes you
need help sometimes I need help and when
I needed help one time I call better
help and they gave it to me next thing
you know I'm on this I'm on the arm I'm
on the FaceTime with a therapist so this
can be it for you you tired of
struggling you crying in your car at
work you write and love letters to
somebody but you don't even have
somebody you might be struggling you can
start communicating in less than 24
hours it's not a crisis line it is
professional counseling done securely
online you'll get timely and thoughtful
responses it's more affordable than
traditional
offline counseling and financial aid is
available better help wants you to start
living a happier life today visit better
help.com slash Theo
that's btter heelp and join the over
500,000 people taking charge of their
mental health and a special offer for
this past weekend listeners get 10% off
your first month at better help calm
slash th EO we all need some help
look who we kidding you don't have the
skills you need all right I'm gonna be
point-blank with you if I if I said hey
do you have the skills you need you
probably wouldn't even answer you'd be
ashamed so that being said so much of
getting where you want in life is
learning new skills and there's no
better place than Skillshare make 2020
the year where you get new skills or
deepen your existing passions with skill
shares online classes personally I'm
taking Simon cynics how to share ideas
that inspire action skill share is an
online learning community that offers
membership with meaning they offer
classes designed for real-life classes
in film and video music and music
production productivity and Finance
skills are waiting for you explore your
creativity at Skillshare dot-com slash
Theo von and get two free months of
premium membership that's two months
free at Skillshare comm slash Theo von
again Skillshare comm slash Theo von
thank you for supporting the podcast but
do you like at this point it's like a
lot of news is just for ratings it seems
like now I mean sometimes do you feel
like you're going into a ballgame and
it's like and it's not as much beliefs
as much as it is like let's see if we
can start some [ __ ] it's kind of like
who's the black gentleman on ESPN every
morning is just start [ __ ] even a
Stephen a Smith yeah you're almost like
the white Stephen a Smith a little bit
you ever feel like that no
no I just I think that a conversation
needs to be started but for what I do
and people that are on say the channel I
think it's a little different I don't
speak the way they speak I speak very
commonly plainly like way people
understand yeah kind of similar to the
way you talk that's why I am where I am
because I speak to people in the way
that they like to be spoken yeah
so Trump does too you know he's a
billionaire from New York he talks like
they talk and they like that yeah so I
don't fit the mold either I mean how
many people on Fox News do you know that
have a lot of them have blonde hair but
have like a nose ring and talk the way I
talk and do what I do
not many is that your only piercing that
one no I have to I have belly button
nose mm-hmm yeah you were hoping it was
something else weren't your name Nick's
had some issues you have some piercings
well I don't work here so good good
point uh no I don't I've thought about
it though but I just don't know what I
would get piercings or tattoos I would
get a tattoo I think you don't have any
talons on my [ __ ] back maybe yeah ABS
that tattoo of me beating the [ __ ] out
of Chris D'Elia on my back maybe good um
no I don't have any I've thought about
it though do you have one I have two
what are they I have one of my wrists
it's an 11 semicolon and I have my state
flower and my state grass on the back of
my neck okay
and that's Montana South Dakota and do
people get them confused a lot North
Dakota and South Dakota never had like
people get it confused from Montana have
you the first we're all just somewhere
out there where it's cold
yeah people yeah I guess yeah a lot of
people just it is interesting how since
over time since we've become more of
like a when you're in Maurel when you're
in LA you just yeah you start to think
this is the whole world you know you
start to think that this is the whole
country you know it just kind of happens
do you notice that a little bit you have
to notice how the perspective is how I
felt there's just two total different
perspectives in the country now like
some people live like in one world and
some people live in another one people
live in the real world and some people
live in California some people ha some
people are more idealistic and some
people are more it seems practical
yeah yeah no I mean it's not practical
here gasps almost $4 a gallon doesn't
sound practical to me yeah a gas tax
that we voted for ourselves like we
voted that in we had a chance to repeal
it and we didn't oh that doesn't really
give me a lot of confidence in my fellow
Californians here who doesn't vote to
repeal a tax on themselves yeah how did
we get here how did we get here but you
know there's a lot of things expensive
man I agree is expensive but there's a
lot of good stuff too yeah it's an ocean
yep and the beach there is there's a lot
of different types of people's a lot of
talented people true yeah I don't know
like I said I don't cross the 405 so
there's a lot of opportunity to do
different things that's true yeah ya
know California is a great place it's
just being run into the ground like you
can't look around here and think things
are going well here like you found
people to judge your talent competition
in a park yeah right and if you did that
now you'd have to do auditions to get
the people from the park because there'd
be so many your audition to go to the
talent show you go out there right now
and say who wants to judge a talent
competition yeah I don't know what you'd
find yeah I don't know what you find
there's also a Twitter account I want
you to follow okay Santa Monica problems
yeah they document it is it good oh yeah
I mean there's a lot of like a lot of
masturbating and stuff they don't even
blur that out it's like this is what we
have here yeah you know using it look
people say it's an unborn if it's not
born yet it doesn't have any it doesn't
have any rights right what do they say
I'm not sure Santa Monica problem dude
armor my dad if we masturbated he made
us bury it in the yard he's like that's
God you have to bury that in the yard he
made us he'll bury the semen L&E yeah
yeah that's crazy right um I heard that
before yeah and her I hadn't heard
either he was getting older though so I
think he might have been you know a
little kind of all over the place um so
you had but you had a thing when you
ever you worked at the blaze right yeah
and you had a whenever you got laid off
I got fired okay so have you tried to
put it dies you don't like things fit
nice you just like things laid off I got
fired and then I had to sue like you
know it doesn't right
things got a little messy there were you
shocked that they because you had a
point of view on abortion right yeah and
were you shocked that they like were you
shocked at how they just did they not
want you to have that point of view yeah
well I it was a conservative place so I
get it but for me I always try to
clarify that comment so here's the way I
feel about it I'm not pro-abortion I
don't believe the government should be
in people's business I believe in
limited government I feel as
conservatives that's what we should
stand up for don't take our guns don't
say who we can and cannot marry don't
get involved in abortion that is not a
government issue and it doesn't do any
good because the government is not going
to prevent it it's just gonna make it
more difficult for people and put people
in danger
so that's where I stand on that limited
government but no they were just looking
for a looking for a way to get me out
the door had things kind of spoiled
already well I was pro Trump and my boss
who's a conservative was anti Trump
Glenn Beck was the biggest never Trump
er that there was I mean election night
we were had to do like a live stream and
he was painting over in the corner to
calm his nerves and at one point it was
like Frank even know like I like a
landscape easy bro if you're gonna
[ __ ] paint some yeah something more
weight you know Glenn's an odd character
right he um
Glenn Beck Glenn Beck yeah Glenn Beck
thinks that he is Walt Disney not like
I'm inspired by Walt Disney like Glenn
Beck thinks he is Walt Disney yeah yeah
there's a lot of weird stuff there's a
lot of weird stuff I encountered does he
have children or not yeah he's got quite
a few children I think yeah he's he's a
later in life Mormon okay it came to the
religion like wasn't born into it okay
um and he lives in Utah no no he was in
Dallas oh and you see you guys buttered
his well he never really spoke to me up
until he fired me and then he was real
chatty about firing me
oh wow and do you think he what do you
think why do you think if you really did
fire he was there something behind that
yeah well when you're pro Trump and then
Trump wins and then you were anti Trump
you kind of look like a jackass unless
what you're saying and you're running a
conservative network but you're against
the Republican president who just won
the presidency doesn't
look Goods you got to get rid of the
person in the building that kind of knew
all this was gonna happen so this is a
real convenient way to kill it cast me
out and were you fear were you upset
well you like nervous when that happened
you had to be scared you like what am I
gonna do now how am I gonna chase I
could sit back for six months and get a
paycheck and just go completely dark and
not do anything and then they wanted to
take over my facebook page which he's
got 4.6 million followers right they
wanted to just delete it
like you're not gonna look mainly what
the lawsuit was over it's like you know
you're not gonna delete my facebook page
yeah what what benefit would he have to
delete my facebook page other than just
being a vindictive a hole right and are
you have you guys seen each other since
it all went down someday yeah someday
they'll be will be a moment do you have
in your head like a vision of where you
guys kind of like like you show back up
with here you know it's almost like the
Channel 4 News team like on that movie
with that Will Ferrell yeah and he comes
in and he's like god this is you know
like the two news teams going at each
other do you have that kind of vision in
your head gonna no I don't know if I'll
ever see good old Glenn Beck again is he
handsome or not um not my not my type
maybe he's your type not my type
oh no I've never been with a man I've
never I've never even thought about it
longer than like I've maybe a second and
a half if I you know and that was only
because I don't know something that pops
in your head when you're jogging or
something for like a brief second you
got to shake it off you know huh
interesting
yeah so anyway my promix figure that's
what she told me on court huh
were you on Court would I go to court
were you on prom court prompt or oh hell
no really
no I wasn't like that popular no I mean
I ran everything I said uh prom but I
wasn't oh we all can counsel then yeah
yes president student council presidents
you gotta present it yeah
oh that girls usually kind of [ __ ]
aggravating I feel like were you I don't
know why was it aggravating I guess I
know I planned everybody's never was so
lazy
yeah I plan to somebody has to do it
let's don't ask
pay for your concession stand like
someone has to go work that and bright
get their friend hotdogs out of the
boiler and given to people yes you're
just standing around you're wishing yet
some airheads and you don't yeah you
know everybody wants tough to get dice
it's kind of like it is nobody wants to
do anything right it's kind of
interesting yet there really isn't a
very strong like it feels like yeah
there's not like a young strong right
right conservative voice you're like oh
I have to do this is that kind of how
you got into like being like like being
so like adamant you have to be though we
have to combat some of this stuff yeah
I've always just been opinion it's just
who I am
yeah but I just didn't understand why we
as conservatives always apologize for
everything that we believe we're so
scared of everybody we don't want to say
what we're thinking because we don't
want to be labeled we don't we called a
name or if you think this you're racist
if you think that you're intolerant if
you believe in border security then you
hate Mexicans no let's just talk about
what our ideas are let's shape the
narrative I'd rather be the one that
does it then have the other side do it
so why are we not doing it the left does
it you're not gonna meet a liberal in
California who's going to be embarrassed
to say they're a liberal but there's a
lot of conservatives walking around here
they won't say anything oh yeah if your
conservative you have to meet up in
basements at night you [ __ ] meet up
behind the Dairy Queen you know you
can't even yeah it seems like it's like
yeah but there's yeah I guess it's just
yeah I never thought about it like that
yeah like people if they're conservative
they can't really have a voice here you
know no way it's gonna change though
it's gonna get so bad here that people
are gonna look at it say how do we get I
would think we people would look at this
date and say well who's running it maybe
he's not doing such a great job maybe
it's time for a change I don't know it
seems like all like it almost seems like
like like a lot of times the liberal the
liberal world or whatever it's like
they'll go to the death being wrong or
not wanting to concede anyway like right
yeah eventually though the people are
gonna well you know I don't know
we got a voter fraud problem we got an
illegal immigrant problem who knows
what's gonna happen to this state but
though really rich people even like
they're really compassionate wealthy
rich liberals they're not going to stay
pay these taxes they're gonna live
somewhere else for five months a year I
want to do this why would anybody want
to want to do this even even the
Liberals that are so compassionate they
don't want to give their money to the
government come on you're gonna get out
of here and then we're gonna have much
right right because then who's gonna pay
for everything not the homeless yeah not
the illegal immigrants they're what's
left here we only are able to continue
at this pace because we have the tech
industry and because we have Hollywood
people aren't making movies here anymore
either
why do you think they're not gonna deal
with all the regulations and how much it
costs to make a movie in California
anymore they're going to Georgia yeah
come on nobody's staying here yeah it's
interesting I mean I definitely the
taxes are definitely egregious it's
crazy it makes you think like yeah why
can't how can I not go somewhere else
um do you so what brought you to live
here then I want to save it I want to
change it I would think that that could
be done if people would wake up and see
all the things that are just happening
here that that's what brought you to Los
Angeles yeah yeah you have to be able to
go somewhere where people don't think
like you do that's why I went to school
in Vegas I lived in Texas which is very
conservative but still it's changing and
I've lived in San Diego now here in LA
so you have to go where people don't
think like you do so whenever you can so
you can Los Angeles and people don't
think like you do here you'd be
surprised though a lot of people come up
to me I'm a conservative yeah they're
Loki can tell anybody can't tell anybody
you can but they're afraid they'll lose
their job I have people that are
prominent people in Hollywood prominent
producers yeah directors everything that
are conservative oh people come to me
all the time people always think like
I'm like running the Underground
Railroad of conservative you know like
I'm [ __ ] you know you think it's a
mullet yeah maybe it could be that it
could be just the [ __ ] sheer
amazingness of myself but it's one of
those two things I think but to be like
hey where's the meeting and I'm like
what are you talking about man it could
be it but yeah people come sometimes in
uh it's definitely scary to think that
you could lose your job to express a
political belief yeah and I think that
that's the kind of thing no one should
ever have to feel
you know and that's the thing that makes
me just scared sometimes about anywhere
someone should never feel that way you
know I think you can always you know
figure it out and discuss it I mean I
was nervous about even having you come
home because I'm like oh well this could
be you know it could be spook it could
be I don't know what I was really scared
of though that's the thing the fear is
like an invisible weirdo that we stop
doing things were worried about what
other people are gonna think about what
we do yeah like I'll tell you this so if
I I've had a lot of people on my shows
or I've gone on other people's shows and
I don't worry about how conservatives
are gonna think of me
don't worry like if I go on with Trevor
Noah on The Daily Show and I oh boy like
conservatives aren't gonna like me
anymore we don't think that way right
but the other side so well what if I if
I even have so much as have this person
on my podcast or I talk to this person
or have a commentary with this person
even if I agree with them or disagree at
them the entire time just like the
thought of being in the same room
people aren't oh he can't do that you'll
offend yeah friend people yeah it's just
not a help it's not personal it's no way
to even get forward in anything it's no
way to discuss you can't have a
discussion unless people are
communicating but people don't want to
have a discussion of you right they
don't like that they don't like it when
the because you know when the truth
comes in the door the bullsh it's got to
go out the window so they don't they
don't like that and they might find that
you might have more in common like vent
people would be surprised like Van Jones
and I are actually friends mm-hmm so
people would be shocked at that clearly
not similar in any other way but it's
like we can have a conversation why not
Trevor no and I actually are pretty good
friends yeah I've had good time een I
was with Chelsea Handler we did a whole
thing together yeah and she was pretty
cool to me I think she's crazy but she
was pretty cool to me so yeah whatever I
was on the view that's how I lost my job
being on the view did you um did you do
you do you feel like sometimes though
that you like you burped like there's
one thing I like kind of share how you
feel right and there's another thing
like bring the [ __ ] yeah you gotta
bring the fire yeah you can't say it
nicely you don't walk into a room when
[ __ ] gets bad here when when socialism
comes knocking on the door because it
already is in California when that
stuff's starting to comment we've got
presidential candidates that are talking
about you don't need a gun we're gonna
come take your guns we want bigger
government we want to take more of your
tax dollars but that's socialism see
what Venezuela is like right
like it's not good yeah they're not
doing well you can't like walk into a
room you like guys I don't think we
should let them take our guns I think
I'd be like no we're not gonna take our
guns we're gonna stand up for ourselves
we're gonna be patriotic we're gonna
stand for the [ __ ] flag we're gonna
have American values that's what we're
gonna do you don't can't tiptoe into a
room and say that you have to come
because that's how they do it right so
why are we active people say that's me
all the time well do you think maybe
you're like too aggressive
Oh liberals never apologize for it so
why should I have to apologize for it
yeah such a load of [ __ ] it's like
well you're controversial you know I'm
conservative and you don't like it so
it's controversial to you personally I
think socialism and trying to get rid of
the Second Amendment and the taxes we
pay in this state and letting felons out
I think that those things are
controversial yeah those are a much yeah
a lot of those should have scary [ __ ]
you know it's a lot of stuff yeah that a
lot of people they it's interesting how
online people are one way and then the
reality of who they are is different you
know yeah the people wouldn't actually I
can't say people wouldn't say that to my
face because you've got said it to my
face plenty of times but look it's a new
year and it's it's a new you and
probably not probably the same old you
but your goals can be new and kaptara
can help it's the free website millions
of people use monthly to find software
for their business kaptara simplifies
the software search to just a few easy
steps first identify the software
features you need then use the smart
search tool and compare them
side-by-side find your best choice at
kaptara dot-com slash Theo say you have
a cookie making company and now you're
at the point where you need to get bags
and you need to get them delivered and
you need to find a way to get all that
done within the same software kaptara is
the place to search kaptara is the free
online resource millions used monthly to
find the best software solution with
over 1 million reviews from real
software users discover everything you
need to make an informed decision search
more than 7
specific categories of software or what
if you want to do real estate and it's
in a rural area you know and you want to
kind of be able to know what houses are
sold for and what's on the market and
and you don't even know where to start
what software is the best for you
well kaptara can help you find it visit
kaptara comm slash Theo for free today
to find the tools to make an informed
software decision for your business that
CA p t-- e RR a.com slash theo kaptara
software selection simplified who's um
who's probably the most handsome policy
he that you've seen besides that guy I
cannot believe you picked that guy Paul
Ryan yeah it was a lot to choose from
what about what about Bill Clinton no
you think he's handsome he always looks
like he has a permanent sunburn and I
know that Donald Trump has a spray tan
but Bill Clinton's look like his face
like he's got a sunburn yeah I could see
that a little bit I think he's getting
us some of that like he's been drinking
but he shouldn't be drinking like the
doctor told him not to drink anymore and
he's still drinking yeah you know you
weren't on a health kick though yeah
Hillary put him on something it scares
me whenever old people get try to get
real healthy cuz it's like oh this could
kill them you know it's like risky if
you didn't that long yeah might as well
yeah to stay yeah yeah but I mean who
else is attractive there are there's not
many yeah you do good-looking male
politician it's like Gavin Newsom and
Justin Trudeau no not oh Justin Trudeau
yes I got married his mother is that the
guy nobody's eyebrows fell off have you
ever seen that you need to google that
to his eyebrows fell off they did you
need to see you need to see it do you
get worried sometimes for yourself like
you get scared being like a like a
conservative voice living in a light
like you does it fit like actually you
actually get spooked yeah I've been to
the police station a few time really
some real credible threats but listen I
believe in the Second Amendment so do
you have a gun at home of course I do if
someone's gonna come into my house
they're gonna know who I am and they're
not
- just give me their political listen
it's not going to turn out well for me
did you write your name on the bullets
or now I could see you totally coming
out with a line of bullets no no I don't
think that would I think we can we can
collaborate on it if you want but uh I
want to go down to the border I know you
invited me to go down there I think you
need to go I think the agents would
really enjoy it I was just down there
and Tito Ortiz came through oh really
yeah I served with him one time at UM at
a homeless shelter down here yeah you
should come to the border though yeah we
go blackhawk you can see the need for
the wall it will show you where there's
no wall we'll show you the wall that's
being built which is so scary to get
like these days is so scary to get stuff
through the news because I feel like the
news has become such a place for
business as opposed to and it probably
always was that's why you got a go right
I when people talk about the border and
they never been to the border when
Democrats say like we don't need a wall
like I haven't seen you down there look
if you're going to our Border Patrol
agents who are saying this is my job and
I think we need a wall because this
would help us do our job better because
a physical barrier would be helpful for
us and then you've got Nancy Pelosi and
Chuck Schumer saying nah we don't need a
wall we don't it's like you're directly
contradicting the people that do that
for a living would you go to a plumber
is like I think that's a problem you
think you need to fix it this way and be
like no you don't know what you're doing
man right pretty sure they do it's like
it's crazy to hire people to do
something and then to not let them do it
you know it's like there's just we
there's so many it's almost like there's
too many checks and balances these days
in some ways
checks and balances but it's just you
got it we had an opportunity listen I
don't let Republicans off the hook
either we sit there for two years with
all that power where's the wall ya know
is there a wall right now or no there's
wall being built I serious I've seen it
in multiple areas of the border it's
being built we need more of it but it's
being built huh I wonder if there's
gonna be a [ __ ] ton of graffiti on it
let them well I think you should put
Donald Trump's face right on the side of
that wall just have them looking right
at you come on over come try it come try
it that's what I put on put it on both
sides I don't care
Wow but Donald Trump on that form on
that wall put a Nancy on that why you
want your people stay away boy Hillary
on that hilarious Hillary and Donald are
starting to look like each other
look Google right now I mean I've seen
that meme yeah yeah Google Donald and
Michael more right now there's a picture
than they put up yesterday so Michael
war just wait no it was a picture they
put up yesterday and I saw it and they
really look alike no getting close
Hillary looks more like Trump in Lorien
Donald start to look similar they look
more similar than Michael Moore are you
excited for the with the election
looming again are you excited because
like it's more of it it's more of a next
time we're we're like you're gonna be
able to get more like in two things are
you looking forward to that 2016 things
were boring before that but things are
exciting every single day with this
president yeah but it's gonna be excite
the debates did you watch the Hillary
Trump debates yes so those were great
yeah whoever we get this time even
better
Biden right now I would feel bad for him
like a pin you I'm at
I just cannot bow I just hope that
everybody keeps getting older and it
keeps getting weirder I want to see a
[ __ ] swimsuit section of the debates
that's what I want to see it get really
really weird you know no I think that's
enough well did you watch the debate
where Trump like he's a troll king yeah
he had bills accusers in the front row
of that debate oh yeah that's crazy huh
that's soaked it's so crazy how like um
do you think they really had beef though
because it seemed like before that
they're all on the same they're all
running around the same world here we
got a question it okay hey Tommy I just
have one question do you ever see
comedians do you go to comedy shows and
listen to our boy Thea ever or other
individuals so I need to go see one of
your shows but you have them places I'm
scared to go to really yeah I have to
where am i I have a Alexandria Cassio
cortez costume and a OC costume have to
wear that
maybe ya know it would be bad cuz you're
not gonna perform unless you're gonna
perform like Hermosa then we got a
comedy club in Hermosa they have a
comedy called you got air you got to
come through optical it's my safe space
you know what are you familiar with Ben
Gleib yeah
so Ben used to be a really good friend
of mine hmm I had been on vouch for him
to come on Fox Nation into our post
debate coverage a couple months ago
vouch for him he's obviously Democrat
he's running for president yeah I saw
that yeah yeah so I vouch for him to
come do this we get to the end of the
coverage he freaks out says this is
[ __ ] pulls his mic out and walks out
the room like dude you're seriously I
vouch for you to come on here he does
that to me and they starts tweeting mean
[ __ ] about me and like what'd I do to
you we are friends
weird [ __ ] happens telling you maybe was
just trying to get like a his moment a
moment yeah a moment yeah it's so wild
how it's become such a moment thing you
know it's like that's one thing I liked
about seeing Bernie on Rogen was and I
know that other politicians I know that
yang was on there I got to check some of
them out I haven't listened all of them
but but I felt like that's why I think
Bernie would get the nomination cuz
people for the first time got to hear
him just talk you know it was like you
almost got to know him a lot better
people say the same thing about Hillary
on Howard Stern that it was just the
first time you got to hear her be like a
regular person without a script and it
was actually kind of interesting yeah no
I think they should all do that yeah I
think they should invite Trump on let
him talk to ya he kind of doesn't on his
own he probably doesn't need the help
yeah what's funny it's like the only
it's almost like sometimes I don't think
senior citizens should be a lot on
Twitter I think there should be like a
cut-off I think it would just help them
all you know like but it's some of this
is only news sources are the only way
they get out you know they're not gonna
cover it they're gonna cover money the
or they're gonna distort it so thank God
for Twitter and Facebook and all the
places you can live stream his stuff
cause otherwise he wouldn't be president
he couldn't get his message out so
that's that's the beauty when you're not
politicking what it what do you like to
like what is I'm trying to just see you
like you know how this was you to have
more fun at that prom you know
I travel a lot for work I mean I work a
lot but I enjoy what I do so it's not
all I do a lot for law enforcement love
law enforcement I love the military I
love our Border Patrol so I do a lot
with them have you seen the new show
called Flint town no it's on Netflix
it's really good okay it's just about
like a police department in Flint okay
so you get to like see Flynn and and
stuff like that yeah we'll watch that is
it real social justice warrior II though
it's not too bad okay because I can't I
can not handle that I stopped watching
the Kardashians and they started doing
that in a show they started doing that
and like it can't even watch it anymore
yeah some definitely over the past
couple years a lot of things
ridiculously got kind of political you
know just like made it made some
entertainment kind of dumb you know but
that's why I think one thing like
podcasting became bigger is because
people can just talk you know they can
just have a conversation let's get
another question that came in here's a
guy right here oh did you ever seen any
other comedians we didn't ask you do you
have comedians that you like or why I
don't go guys scared but I used to love
Chelsea Chelsea Handler I used to like
that was my favorite show Chelsea Lately
ani I wash it every single night
my favorite wow yeah I love Chelsea ham
and then it got again it got weird well
she got I mean she just got real
political yeah see and in that that what
was that that Netflix show yeah that
wasn't funny anymore she was she lost
being funny a while ago I think about
chewy yeah all right you chewy died yeah
that's sad I wash I show all through
high school yeah yeah it's a good show
let's get this question here
hey Tommy hey Theo John here from New
Jersey and big fan of both years and I
had a quick question for Tommy
I saw you went and saw Morgan Wayland a
couple months ago on Instagram and I
wanted to see what your opinion was
who's got the better mullet Theo or
Morgan and he DM me too when he's like I
love feels like you need to be on the
podcast and he said well he needs to
invite me I said I'm gonna hook it up
I'm gonna pitch it there is a well look
at that beautiful cut huh I'm telling
you he needs to be on we have similar
shoulders to look at his shoulders kind
of very nice yeah that's his aesthetic
did you meet him yeah he's a good friend
of mine
yeah I'm gonna go see him in Dallas next
week you are yeah you're going to Europe
so you're kind of out of luck but yeah
I'm out of luck right now let me see a
little bit yeah we got to hear more
about Morgan willing who has a better
mullet do you think I don't really have
a mother I have long hair you have them
what it's a mullet it's like definitive
whatever live what do you think I'm all
it is I think a mullet is something
that's really really more like um look
up mullet here we go like this here's a
Filipino guy right here with how is that
different or semi Korean this guy but
here's the thing is that a mullet
yeah that's um well a mullet is anything
that shorter in the front and longer in
the back okay okay a big stair-step the
big thing is called the skullet and
that's when you have no hair in the
front and still have long hair what
about rather skullet right there happen
to rat tails smooth that kids in South
Dakota they got a rat tail like what is
this
my brother has well I don't know what do
you have your hair like when you were
when you were a kid I mean nothing
creative yeah nothing weird did you do
pigtails you do something what you do do
you do barrettes sure you did there was
just the normal kid stuff you know do a
headband you know it a headband I had a
headband yeah I did the whole the whole
90s thing okay you know the whole 90
situation did you walk with your bookbag
on the front or the back
what you mean the front some people put
it on the front so people don't steal
their stuff there must be a California
thing we don't worry about that in South
Dakota we were all on the back man you
[Laughter]
get your ass kicked in South Dakota you
walk around with a backpack in the front
like people that carry like the babies
in the front come on
I saw someone lax that night no [ __ ]
with it look backpack in the front I'm
like what are you worried about dude
well he's worried pickpockets he's
worried about your friend what's his
name
oh right or Tony Tony sneaking in there
your Dada thing in there like that well
you don't talk about him he's hot no
it's fine yeah I mean
so definitely an la thing that's because
people do that so stuff doesn't get
stolen yeah not gonna steal and South
Dakota I mean not that people don't
steal right but there's not that many of
us there so you can pretty much figure
it out right and there's a little bit
more yeah there's a little bit more I
think in in places like that there's a
little bit more like rural justice kind
of that happens you know right there's a
little bit more like okay someone's not
going to go do that because they know
they're going to suffer people are armed
we just saw that in Texas but like in
California you do something to somebody
we're gonna stab me with their needle
but what is the average person gonna do
give you like a good talking-to
yeah you know nothing tweet about it
glitter yeah
glitter bombs in your face or what let's
get one or two more questions before you
have Morgan oh no I mean I would love
that Morgan on I'm telling you gonna set
it up I'm gonna set it up I want master
P on I'll set that up too you will yeah
I got the I got although any of the
rappers you know who do you want who was
like my ultimate person that I like to
Kapernick really yeah just needs to
happen yeah have you seen interest have
you seen my Kaepernick video I haven't
seen it you have to watch it
Sony 75 million views on that sucker
yeah yeah people were so as people were
so heated about the Kaepernick thing you
have to watch it sometimes do you think
that he was that person or do you know
hundred percent not a hundred thousand
he was pissed I'm gonna tell you the
story I get fired up about this okay he
was pissed you fired up about a lot
that's okay that's good it's interesting
moments yeah you have some chill moment
some chill moments but tell you what
happened with the Kaepernick okay he got
put on the bench Blaine Gabbert became
the starter so he was over in the corner
pissy and he thought what can I do what
can I do I know I'll make this I'll make
this a social justice warrior moment for
myself and then I'll start kneeling and
sitting on them it's like you didn't do
it when you were the starter you did it
when your ass was on the bench yeah and
now it's just a joke it's now if he's
workout and stuff do you think what I
heard was that he was dating a girl yeah
who told him I really got into it yeah
like hey listen you need to you know
you're kneeling for oppression
we're depressed all these years you
weren't oppressed when you were making
nineteen million dollars
you were in a press but now all of a
sudden you're on the bench you know
they're probably not gonna we're not
gonna give you what you are not going to
renew your contract and then then you
become oppressed yeah what they do need
you do have to like but some of the
outrace some outrage stuff it helps
shine a light on things I think
sometimes it doesn't do a great job I
thought I was kneeling for the anthem
how does that agree I don't know if that
was the most I think yeah I think the
bigger thing was just like you know
people need to look at how black people
are treated in America I think that
would it would have just been better to
have some organized way or you know or
just some other way of doing that but I
think I think it did its job I just
think it was a little it was just it
wasn't organized real I don't know if
but who knows if they had that plan from
the beginning who knew that it would
spawn such a thing you know such a
fervor of people like you know that that
people need to think about the way that
they look at and treat black people you
know like for the flag and saying that
this country is a horrible country it
oppresses people like what are you
trying to advance there you're also
looking at a game where in hit work you
have black people and white people
playing together black people and white
people watching at home in the stands oh
yeah nobody nothing reason yeah people
together and you you wanted to use
something to divide people and
especially an activity like sports that
really brings people together when we
talked about how this country is less
divided and people would have you
believe that's the kind of stuff that
divides people it's like not a place for
it if you want to go have a rally or you
want to have your activism or whatever
you have to do it in the place where
people are getting along and people are
coming together over sports and love of
country that's just an American thing
and you you want to make that about you
and you're a little moment where you
hate this country no no I don't have no
time for that do you think that do you
think there do you have like a is there
like an end goal to like because the
conflict in this discussion of conflict
and is going forever right do you feel
like you have like an end like a place
where it's like okay
I'll be happy I think Trump being
elected just showed people that there's
a lot of power in the Forgotten American
so that was the first hurdle but now
it's just it's not I don't ever want to
change someone's mind that's not the
goal of what I do is to get rid of
liberals and make everyone conservative
I don't think everyone should be
conservative I think there's a nice
balance in this country of liberals and
conservatives that's how it's always
been
but the problem is that the Liberals
started to silence conservatives
conservatives got scared to stand up for
their beliefs and then pretty soon
you're just being overrun and those are
the values the loudest voice in the room
is the one that makes the decisions and
that's not just in politics but it's in
corporate America sand everything so you
have that one person that says now
anybody who disagrees with me is a
racist and a bigot then pretty soon
people just stop saying something and we
lose this country it just sends into
madness so that's that's the the result
I want to get is not agreement
it's just respecting other people's
opinions and for conservatives to just
get a backbone which we did in 2016
we're going to again in 2020 but it
can't just live and die with Trump you
can't just have Trump eventually he's
gonna be gone and we're gonna need
somebody else that's gonna be able to
rile people up but it shouldn't just be
that one person if you're a liberal I
don't care I talk to the Liberals all
the time I have a lot of friends who are
liberals don't agree with me on a lot of
things a lot of conservatives who don't
agree with me and a lot of my beliefs we
can still talk yeah but until we get to
that place my job isn't done so you just
got to get pissed off about it and
they're not gonna take my guns tell you
that I know I know I know you said that
I know that I know that you think that I
know that no they should don't ever take
anybody's guns I mean there's just too
many [ __ ] guns you could never get all
the guns dude if you tried to get set
even if you try to go door to door and
get 70 guns it would take you probably a
year yeah two years maybe to get 70 guns
you never and there's there's hundreds
of millions of guns can you do any dance
moves or not can you do any I can yeah
I'm not gonna do them right now no I
don't ya know I you can I like rap music
I tell you that yeah yeah I do there's a
different would you ever go to the use
together go to the club or you like I
had a yeah oh yeah I went to school in
Vegas did you ever date any black guys
in Vegas or no no because I did that oh
I'll play that and then I did it in
Mormon after that oh wow yeah
what is this guy AB NIT hey Tommy hey
Theo hope you guys are doing well so my
question is from what I see on the
internet there's a lot of hate
surrounded with Tommy's name and just in
general a a lot of racist comments about
it a lot of just horrible things said
about her and I just wanted to know how
do you deal with that like how do you
deal with on all this negativity and
continue to like put out content and be
just a positive person thank you
game bro it was nice yeah nice young man
there seemed like a nice man is a hand
you can see his hand in the video
there's at least one hand we responding
to his question I don't really care what
people think about me that I did I don't
have a respect for if they say nasty
things I just don't have a respect for
it so why would water let that bother me
if I was gonna let everything that
people called me it said about me bother
me I wouldn't do what I did live in a
hole
yeah that's now when you bring it up I
got all these the game went after me you
know the game the old rappers right but
also you're kind of an easy target right
yeah I mean I think it's an easy win for
them that's an easy win soon easy win
but who really wins right yeah nobody no
nobody ever wins in a Twitter war first
of all ever
I mean Twitter is most of Twitter is
[ __ ] people I think who are not even
working in just yelling out they're
definitely not working there's no it's
absolutely become unbelievable how yeah
but people that that's why I worry about
the younger generation because they get
all their validation off of Instagram
and the things that people say about
them or don't say about it right so it's
more what people think of how you are
yeah more about the idea than it is
about the reality yeah people will go
places I'm sure you see it all the time
too they're there just for the Instagram
photo or they're there just to say they
were there but you're not really there
or they're not really they don't even
really want to be there yeah they're
doing things to get likes and validation
if they don't get that then they feel
like they're less of a person that's
we're getting into a real bad spot with
with young people in social media well
just because it's so like at that point
there you're just a victim of kind of
whatever as long as you're gonna look a
certain way as
as everybody looks in way it almost
becomes like that black mirror episode
where it was like as long as you bathe a
certain way to people then they liked
you and it reflected like an actual
social score that you kept and you had
to keep a certain level yeah so people
are not being themselves right so that's
another thing I want to inspire I think
you do that a lot too that's why you
have the fanbase that you have is you
inspire people just be yourself whatever
that is just be that and if they don't
like it do you really care I mean do I
do I really care what these people say
or think about me no it doesn't really
affect me yeah they don't as long as I'm
not paying my bills doesn't really
affect me yeah they think about me or
what they say about me it's they're
taking the time out of their day to say
something nasty yeah that kind of sucks
word it yes some of that she's just
[ __ ] like get a life don't you feel
like you kind of whine when people say
that it's like you took I say sometimes
I respond to people on my Instagram
they'll say look your your this or your
so irrelevance like you came on my page
you looked at my picture and you went to
comment you took time out of your life
to say something about me clearly I'm
getting to you in some way right so I
win I still won yeah yeah I think it's
interesting like uh yeah some girl
messaged me and she's like oh I can't
hey I can't communicate with you if
these the type of guests you're gonna
have on you know and it just made me
feel like oh that's so I just felt bad
for her you know kind of it just felt
like I don't know I just it's kind of
scary how I don't know it's it's it's
scary how like it's so easy for us to
just like what we like and also just to
get served only that by like algorithms
and stuff now it's like you can stay in
a world where you never know anything
else exists you know like you can be a
New England Patriots fan and you've
clicked on a couple of things a
sweatshirt or something you think about
buying and next thing you know all your
facebook feed for the rest of your life
is just you think everything is about
Julian Edelman you know what I'm saying
like the entire world because that's
what they're feeding you you know so
it's really I mean it makes sense kind
of how people are just really kind of
one way or the other these days or a lot
of people are because that's all they're
getting fed you know people also feel
more comfortable when they can put
somebody in a box yeah same thing with
me and coming out and saying what
did about being pro-choice like well we
thought you were conservative now you're
saying something that doesn't fit the
mold right get back in your box that
makes people really uncomfortable when
you're just a free thinker and you just
do what you want to do and you think the
way you actually think if you won't like
that it's like you got to be here you
got to be here do you think but do you
think like moving forward that we're
headed towards having hopefully more
political parties having things be a
little bit more diverse in that space
like it's got it's it's a little crazy
to think with how how things aren't just
one way or the other a lot of times that
there that there should be more options
that are real options you know I think
you have that with the individual the
thing that I worry about people say we
need more a more of a party system well
they have the same thing they have that
in Europe it doesn't doesn't necessarily
change things it just makes elections
more complicated but people are so lazy
now that they don't even research things
as it is can you imagine if we actually
had to take the time to research
multiple parties with multiple
candidates and try to make a majority
like people just need to it's easy to
say that people just need to be more
active and what they're voting for and
learning and stop trying to please
people just do it what you think is
right yeah and I think less government I
don't think there's a person out there
that thinks I think government should be
bigger and control more of what we do is
scary I don't think that you know
whether you agree with all the tenets of
conservatism or Donald Trump you don't
have to I don't but I think we can agree
that we know how to best spend our money
better than the government better than
people in DC well yeah I mean the
government look out look at these in the
national debt I mean the government
hasn't done the best [ __ ] job that's
why sometimes when you know when they
appeal to like poor people or something
like we're gonna help you and stuff it's
like you have been saying this forever
and not it's just I don't know I think
it's interesting to see when people go
against the norm you know to try that's
why that's one reason I think Kanye is
interesting because he's just you know I
don't really know where his political
views lie really but he's trying to buck
the system he might be a psychopath as
well but yeah he's trying to be [ __ ]
as brave as you can be the easiest thing
to be is exactly what is most
comfortable mm-hmm ya know I think we
all need to get out of the box
don't let anyone yeah
we all need to be two million and move
to out Los Angeles there's a
one-question end on and we're getting
out of here what's up guys this is Alan
calling in from New York I got a
question for you Tommy I know you got
some strong viewpoints they get people
pretty riled up
I was just wondering your thoughts on
baby Billy running through the house
with the pickle in his mouth
oh that's righteous jim says have you
seen that no why no I didn't quite hear
what do you even say what can you run
through the house with a pickle in his
mouth baby Billy keep bringing a picture
of Uncle baby Billy you haven't seen the
righteous gemstones no you would love it
you do yeah Oh big pickle fan you are
yeah great food there's no calories in a
pickle did you know that
yeah man where would they put a calorie
in there if you open a pickle up there's
no place even for a calorie in it that's
uncle baby Billy right there
okay look I'm just not he's one of a
kind dude he fired one of the top six or
700 minutes ever been alive oh yeah you
would love this guy he um yeah the show
is called righteous gemstones yeah take
a look at that it's really good all the
people that said you play soccer growing
up know soccer is a communist sport well
let's go to the sports every time you
hear about a sport where people got
killed after the game because they lost
it's always soccer bro it's never
something else this is real it's also
like really fragile sport yeah yeah I
think it's very it's a very fragile
sport don't you think yeah Billy if you
bump into the guy they call a foul yeah
I don't think it's a man's sport it just
doesn't seem very manly to me yeah at
all I've never been a fan of soccer I
think it's yeah it's it's boring you
know growing up if you have to have a
sport there's no actual bleachers you
got to bring your own chair there's
already about you see those parents
specially in South Dakota you see
parents do not there and they're gonna
foldable chairs like freezing and
watching their kids
yeah Burton like their kids [ __ ] good
and everything in another soccer game
yeah no that's hilarious
um Tommy Lehren thank you so much for
coming thanks for having me hopefully
you don't get too much [ __ ] yeah no I
mean I have no idea you know like we
have all kind of people in here and
you're welcome back we're gonna go to
the border
oh yes truly you're gonna have Morgan
wall anon - I haven't had Morgan Wolin
on do ya you're like the student council
president you're like look some of this
[ __ ] maybe happen yeah yeah I just gonna
pay me a little bit I'm a capitalist
into the day rev-share deal here okay
I'll bring you a lot of good people yeah
yeah okay
Oh middleman OPI pants I like this
yeah I like this um do you think that
women should be allowed to be able to
sell themselves sexually if they want to
talk about that no I don't I don't know
I mean I wouldn't that we're good where
we were yeah I said can we get ended on
that don't figure so that's everywhere
but oh yes truth popular in Vegas yeah
then they get traffic let people don't
actually want to burn it actually
traffic that much there's so much less
trafficking on when they really say it's
not bumper-to-bumper with [ __ ]
hookers you know it's like occasionally
there's a hooker you know and some are
being kind of mismanaged
I think there's definitely a middle like
kind of a and then sometimes I think
every now and then though somebody's
being taken advantage of traffic yeah
yeah somebody just make them work yeah
yeah sometimes just a lazy hooker no
work traffic not sex trafficking but
just they traffic people to work on
farms and oh oh yeah there is more
there's a little bit of slavery going on
a little yeah but I wonder where it's at
I wonder what states have still have a
little bit of slavery in them well the
people are getting traffic to work here
is to work in agriculture yeah avocados
there's a lava cottage basically yeah
almond milk oh dude squeeze in the
[ __ ] home it's gotta stop uh
time'll Aaron thank you so much thank
you
[Music]
on the breeze and I feel I'm full and
like these leaves I must be I'll share
this piece of thought it's gonna take
little town for me to sell that parking
brake and let myself
[Music]